which daughter is this so singing with
the dog
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god it's so cute which daughter is
that
that's maggie that's the middle daughter
yeah and uh
stromboli's the dog's name yeah very
italian i like it yeah well he's he's uh
he's just a he's he's a glorified bird
dogs all he is but he's italian
caught i think he's called an italian
bronco so we had a family of those dogs
and he's the last one left well we have
one more at the farm but
but uh so we named them all italian
names i love that y'all are both singers
and even your dog sing that's awesome
it really is in the family be fair
strong things a lot better than me i'm
probably the worst singer in the house
oh shut up i've seen you live that's
what i found so funny
i've seen you live you and faith and you
came backstage and you were like oh man
if i know how to sing better i was like
you did an
awesome job of singing along i was like
y'all both killed it like
you're so humble whatever
you